you know for nearly a century this has
been the go-to site for legendary
football games
concerts and now even a coven 19 testing
site
yeah the pandemic has forced this
historic landmark to cancel hundreds of
events losing over
16 million dollars in revenue so the
rose bowl legacy foundation needs your
help to keep it afloat
visit inspire2022.org america
stadium needs america campaign for more
info
and do us a favor give which you can we
really do want to create even more
memories and history right here
absolutely you know by the way it is
also an extort year for the super bowl
halftime show
30 years of memorable performances and
you better believe
e.t has been there every step of the way
[Music]
[Applause]
the new kids performed at the super bowl
halftime
back in 19 30 years ago this year
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the first time you know that
they had
a major pop act do a big massive
production we did it with disney
which at the time you know i was trying
to be a tough young man i was like why
are we doing this disney thing
to look back now and see what halftime
has become it's a pretty cool honor
[Music]
you have performed actually at two super
bowl halftime shows i have in
minneapolis way back in the day it was
very cold outside but it was hot in that
stadium
gloria's first halftime performance was
back in 1992
et was invited to rehearsals the then 34
year old trained like an athlete in
preparation i've been working out
very hard probably about two and a half
hours a day
[Applause]
by 1993 the world's biggest pop star at
the time
michael jackson was headlining the
halftime show here at the rose bowl i am
so excited to be part of super bowl 27.
[Music]
from then on e.t started our tradition
of taking our spot
inside and all around the state
[Music]
in 1999 cheer told us she was absolutely
freaking out leading up to singing the
national anthem
i was thinking this morning if i screw
up tonight i have to start a new career
and move to someplace else
[Music]
you rocked you were awesome
the new decade brought a new generation
of pop stars to the halftime stage
in 2001 then couple brittany and justin
sang alongside aerosmith
[Music]
[Applause]
is it hard to keep a relationship with
you guys for being so busy
um it's a little hard but it's all about
trust and he loves me and i love him and
we just try to work it out so
justin returned to the super bowl stage
with janet jackson in 2004.
[Applause]
[Music]
and the phrase wardrobe malfunction
would be ingrained into pop culture
forever
e.t was backstage with justin moments
later still unaware of the controversy
he'd created you got nasty with miss
jackson hey man
it's every man's dream we thought it
would be cool instead of me just coming
up by myself to kind of mix it up with
her
but it is prince's 2007 performance
in the midst of a miami rainstorm that
is wildly hailed
as the greatest in super bowl history
especially in the weather purple rain is
a perfect song
and when it comes to super bowl royalty
look no further than queen b
starting in 2004 when she belted out the
national anthem
and when those rockets in pyro it just
was
i still have to calm down i still have
that rush
in 2013 her headlining act was so
electrifying
the power went out
[Applause]
god was on my side so i'm very very
happy that it went well
and the power went out after okay was it
you were you the power outage did you
oh lord i don't know
beyonce returned three years later to
kick off coldplay's 2016 halftime show
[Applause]
many said she stole the show
taraji p henson didn't help the
situation
during coldplay's performance she
tweeted quote yes
hashtag maroon 5 is life to me
i don't know how if you know how it goes
down in the sweets
put a lot of drinks in there kool-aid
i'm human i make
i made a mistake you're human it happens
come on i drank the kool-aid
[Music]
of course maroon 5 did headline in 2019.
adam's shirtless move ripped straight
from the jagger playbook
made him the most meme to man in
halftime history
during his only super bowl interview
adam told me
he had been training hard i've been
treating it like i'm about to play
in the super bowl myself working out a
lot yeah
even taking care of myself for the past
30 days
[Music]
and with just three days to go before
the weekend makes his halftime debut
last year's co-headliner j.lo has this
advice good luck
it was intense i'm happy that it's not
me this year and it's the weekend